It is one of the seven virtues of Christianity.
It used to have a central place in Roman ethics
and Judaism as well. Today, we remain deeply
impressed by the idea of charity, but often
from a distance, without probing the concept
too deeply, with little attempt to practise
it systematically. It’s something we might
have recourse to when we’re moved by a documentary
on the TV or have some loose change left over
after the holidays. At its most basic, charity
means: giving someone something they need
but can’t get for themselves. And normally
that’s understood to mean something material.
We overwhelmingly associate charity with giving
money. The heroes of Christianity are exemplars
of such charity. Outside the city, Saint Francis
comes across a poor man. His garments are
thin and ragged. Winter is coming on and coats
are expensive. The saint is moved to charity.
But, at its core, charity goes far beyond
finance. It is about recognising that a person
needs help with something that they can’t
do for themselves – and that their helplessness
is not a sign of wickedness or sin, but is
part of the human condition. We freely give
because we appreciate how often we wouldn’t
have made it if other people had not – at
key points, in different contexts – cut
us some slack. It is in relationships that
charity becomes particularly necessary. Here
we don’t generally require the charity of
money, cloaks and free meals. What we are
short of is charity of interpretation: that
is, a charitable perspective on our weaknesses,
eccentricities, anxieties and follies – failings
that we are unable to explain or win sympathy
for, that we merely act out, with immaturity
and hurt. It might be that one person in a
couple has badly messed up in their professional
life. They made a significant decision at
work that played out badly. They got severely
criticised; there was talk of court action.
For months, they were very agitated, and hard
to live with. They couldn’t articulate their
fears. They were sullen and irascible. Their
partner might have added stern admonitions
to those of the regulator, the senior management
and people on Twitter… They could have concluded
that their partner was inept, greedy, maybe
a bit unprincipled. But instead, a charitable
soul does the work the partner has not been
able to do. They do the explaining for them.
They understand enough about their past to
have a picture of where their impatience and
over-ambition came from. They hold in mind
what happened with their parents and with
the move to another country and with the brother
who died too young. They lend a picture of
who the ‘beggar’ is that is sufficiently
generous and complex as to make them more
than just the ‘fool’ or ‘weirdo’ they
could so easily have been dismissed as. The
genuinely charitable person gives generously
from a sense that they too stand in need of
charity. Not right now, not over this, but
in some other area. They know that self-righteousness
is merely the result of a faulty memory, an
inability to hold in mind – at moments when
one is totally right – how often one has
been deeply and definitively in the wrong.
Charity remembers how there might still be
goodness amidst a lot of evil. Charity keeps
in mind that if someone is tired and stressed,
they are liable to behave appallingly. Charity
is aware that when someone shouts an insult
they are not usually revealing the secret
truth about their feelings. They are trying
to wound the other because they feel they
have been hurt – usually by someone else,
whom they don’t have the authority to injure
back. Charity is interested in mitigating
circumstances; in bits of the truth that can
cast a less catastrophic light on our follies.
In financial matters, charity tends always
to flow in one direction. The philanthropist
may be very generous, but usually they stay
rich; they are habitually the giver rather
than the recipient. But in life as a whole,
and especially in relationships, charity is
unlikely ever to end up being one-sided: who
is weak and who is powerful changes rapidly
and frequently. You are likely to be, as it
were, a patron in one area and a beggar in
another. So we must be kind not only because
we are touched by the suffering of others
but because we properly understand that we
too will soon be in urgent need of an equally
vital dose of charity in some other part of
our lives.